Los Angeles ganz
unten wir sind in Skidrow der übelsten
Gegend der Stadt eine der gefährlichsten
in ganz
Amerika wir sind unterwegs mit dem
General einem früheren Schwerverbrecher
er lebt hier auf der Straße seit fast 20
Jahren general Dogan genießt Respekt er
kümmert sich kämpft für die Obdachlosen
hier 61 ist er jetzt und Skid Row ist
sein
Leben sein kleiner Sohn lebt weit weg
bei der Mutter alle zwei Monate besucht
er
ihn sein Zuhause ist hier im
[Musik]
Zelt das hier ist alles was
sitzt das hier ist meine Ideenschmiede
wie bei den Ägyptern die haben kleine
Pyramiden gebaut in die sie gingen um zu
denken auf die Art kann ich hier eine
Menge erledigen und ich kann mich von
der Welt zurückziehen die so grausam
ist general Dogon das war sein Spitzname
im Knast zuerst kam die Drogen sucht
dann die Verbrechen bewaffneter
Banküberfall Raubüberfälle 11 Jahre saß
er Zeit zum Lesen über die Rechte von
Häftlingen er schrieb haftbeschwerden
und wurde so zum
Aktivisten jetzt arbeitet er für eine
Hilfsorganisation verdient 1500$ im
Monat 1000 für Frau und Kind 500 für
sich skid R meint er sei politisch
gewollt weg mit den Obdachlosen hierher
oder gleich in den
Knast Armut und Obdachlosigkeit wurden
in dieser Stadt immer kriminalisiert
Obdachlose werden betrachtet als Bürger
dritter Klasse die entarteten unserer
Gesellschaft und so wurde nie Geld hier
reingesteckt dann wurde investiert aber
nicht in Wohnungen sondern in die
Polizei der Großteil des Geldes das hier
reinfließt geht in polizeiliche
Überwachung aber nicht dahin uns ein
Dach über dem Kopf zu
verschaffen
[Musik]
ganze Viertel wurden in den USA
abgegrenzt und konsequent vernachlässigt
vor allem Wohnviertel von schwarzen
redlining hieß
das in den rot markierten Gebieten gab
es keine Banken die Menschen bekamen
keine Kredite für den Hausbau keine
Versicherung kaum Ärzte Krankenhäuser es
gab keine Supermärkte nicht
und hier wirkt es
fort blanke Armut und
Hoffnungslosigkeit fast 10 000 Menschen
leben in Skidrow auf der Straße die
Vereinten Nationen nannten die Situation
vor einigen Jahren unmenschlich mitten
im reichen Amerika im Blumenladen an der
Ecke Aufsteller mit fertig gebundenen
trauergrenzen so hoch ist hier die
Gewalt dass Grenze ständig gebraucht
werden
Pete white hilft den Obdachlosen mit
seiner Organisation la CAN für die auch
general Dogon arbeitet er möchte
aufräumen mit einigen Mythen über
[Musik]
Obdachlosigkeit wenn die ganze Politik
auf der Annahme basiert dass Leute
obdachlos sein wollen oder darauf sie
Hal drogenabhängig sind oder psychisch
krank dann die regier zu tun sie trägt
dann keine Verantwortung aber wenn man
über Wohnraum spricht der bezahlbar ist
der verfügbar ist dann spricht man über
Strukturen man merkt schnell dass es ein
strukturelles Problem ist und kein
persönliches dauerhafte Unterbringung in
Wohnungen also ist der Schlüssel das hat
auch die Stadt Los Angeles erkannt und
räumt die Zeltcamps weg mit den
ungeliebten und allzu sichtbaren Zeichen
der Armut der
politischen Versagens aber es fehlt
bezahlbarer Wohnraum eine
Einzimmerwohnung kostet in Los Angeles
durchschnittlich
2000 früher sagt Pete white wurden
Häuser mal für Menschen
gebaut jetzt sind Häuser Teil von
größeren Anlageportfolios die an der
Börse gehandelt werden Gebäude dienen
auch dazu dass wohlhabende Menschen D
ihr Geld parken können oder für
steuerabschreibungen
gebä als W als Werkzeug als Vehikel für
Reichtum es ist wirklich eine grausame
Bestrafung so viele Menschen in Los
Angeles auf der Straße zu haben und
einige wenige genießen die Beute aus dem
Wohnungsmarkt oder dem
[Musik]
Finanzmarkt im Obdachlosenheim fand sie
den Weg in ein städtisches Programm und
hat jetzt eine eigene
Wohnung es ist ein völliger Neuanfang
für mich ich liebe meine neue Wohnung
sie ist gemütlich ich liebe mein
riesiges Bett und einfach hier sitzen zu
können zu malen Musik zu hören fern zu
sehen und allein zu sein das ist schön
das habe ich
vermisst
in dem städtischen Programm sind in
jedem Haus Sozialarbeiter die den
Bewohnern helfen auch langfristig wieder
auf die Beine zu kommen aber es fehlen
htausende Wohnungen so versucht die
Stadt im Eiltempo zu bauen wird mit
städtische Gebäude und Hotels
um baut selbst zeltstätte aber
organisiert mit Ausstattung mit Betten
Zahnbürsten und Seife Duschen und
Toiletten als Zwischenlösung für
Obdachlose und die Behörden versuchen zu
verhindern dass Menschen überhaupt ihre
Wohnungen
verlieren wir möchten den Zustrom in die
Obdachlosigkeit aufhalten denn wir
bringen etwa 200 Menschen jeden Tag in
Wohnungen unter aber etwa 220 werden am
selben Tag ob
und nur wenn wir es schaffen diesen
Zustrom aufzuhalten dann können wir
Obdachlosigkeit wirksam
bekämpfen das heißt selbst mit den 700
Millionen Dollar die Kalifornien zur
Verfügung gestellt hat läuft man dem
Problem immer noch nur
hinterher die Aktivisten von la CAN
sehen trotzdem Licht am Ende des
Tunnels inzwischen sind es nicht mehr
nur schwarze arme Menschen jetzt sind es
auch weiße und Asiaten die in unserem
Wirtschaftssystem kämpfen ich hoffe dass
wenn so viele andere neue Gesichter sich
einreihen bei der Armut dass wir dadurch
die Macht aufbauen können tatsächlich
eine Politik durchzusetzen bei der
Menschen werdvoller sind als
[Musik]
Profit der amerikanische Traum
unerreichbar aber ein kleiner Traum ist
immer drin general versucht ein bisschen
Geld zu sparen damit er vom Zelt in ein
Wohnmobil ziehen
kann wenn man hier auf den Boden schaut
dann sieht man die Ratten und die
Kakalaken und alle haben einen Ort wo
sie hingehen können nur wir Obdachlose
nicht wir leben wilder als die
Höhlenmenschen denn die hatten ja ihre
Höhle und wie wichtig wohnen ist sieht
man daran dass der Höhlenmensch ja sogar
nach seiner Behausung benannt wurde und
hier liegen die Menschen einfach auf dem
Boden herum mein Wunsch wäre dass jeder
eine Wohnung hat wie die Ratten und die
Kakalaken dass auch wir unsere Höhle
haben in die wir kriechen
können es wird Abend in Los Angeles und
während die Menschen aus den glitzernden
Bürogebäuden in ihre schönen Häuser
aufbrechen bereiten Sie sich direkt
daneben in Skidrow auf eine weitere
harte Nacht vor
[Musik]